chapter 290 of my academia is perhaps my
most anticipated spoiler review
ever because yes it finally happened the
identity of derby has been revealed
after all these years
ever since he was introduced all those
years ago it's been a complete secret i
mean
we as fans suspected what it was but
still there was never that concrete
confirmation
but today we finally got it the title of
this chapter is dabi's dance
which is appropriate because he
literally starts busting out
joker style moves as he reveals his
identity to the world
before we get into it don't forget to
sub as i probably have the biggest
collection
of dabby theories and explanations on my
channel so yeah be sure to hit that
button
and let's get into it the chapter kicks
off away from the battlefield
as we see ray todoroki sitting in a
hospital room
her eyes are wide open as on the tv is
literally a video of
derby which i assume is being broadcast
to televisions all across japan
thanks to our boy skeptic the video on
tv was clearly pre-recorded
as we see dabby sitting down in the
paranormal liberation front mansion
and he's not wearing a top so all the
scars on the upper half of his body
are visible later in this chapter we'll
see what he says in this broadcast
but for now the chapter switches over to
shigaraki's perspective
and it follows on from this moment in
the last chapter when gigantomachia
finally makes it to the battlefield
afl claims that this was really nice
timing because shiguraki's body is
basically on life support at this point
i mean yes he does have regeneration but
it's been slowing down and he's taken
several smashes from deku from
endeavor with his prominence burn as
well as attacks from shoto
and nedurey very recently shoto thinks
to himself that he won't be able to beat
shigeraki and machia at the same time
so he and neduri combined for an
ultimate move to finish off shigaraki
but at the last second makiya swings his
hand to grab shigaraki
with the blowback pushing shoto to the
ground we then see that tenure is
starting to carry back ago away from the
battlefield
but the barely conscious back ago tells
ida to put him down
as he needs to win this fight against
shigaraki obviously either refuses his
request
and reminds bakugo that his internal
organs were ripped which is
a valid observation i don't think
bakugou should even be attempting
to get back into the fight moving on to
endeavour
he's been lying on the ground in a whole
heap of pain and his internal dialogue
he kind of like
apologizes to hawks for allowing
shigaraki to wake up
in endeavour's mind the reason shigaraki
woke up is because of his own failures
and he goes on to think that his lungs
are a bit burnt after the last
prominence burn
meaning he is now at his limit this
right here is the moment
when debbie greets endeavour while still
standing on gigantomachia's shoulders
and the number one hero looks up from
the ground and just says
darby the villain replies by telling
endeavor not to call him that name
before whipping out a bottle of
mysterious liquid i don't know
what exactly this liquid is maybe
someone who's dyed their hair before can
tell me
but dabi pours this liquid all over his
hair and his hair begins to change color
from
black to white in the manga it's been
shown many times
that toyotaroki had white hair although
in the anime it was red hair so
i guess this scene will be slightly
different when we see it animated in
season six
with dabby's hair now totally white he
tells endeavour not to call him darby
because toya is a great name darby is
toyah
confirmed we've had all the theories you
know you if you're a follower of me
you've seen it on my channel many times
dabi is toyah we've thought it for a
long time it is now 100 confirmed and
man this is the best news to wake up to
before we move on
i just got to say that horukoshi is a
genius because it was exactly 100
chapters ago
in in chapter 190 that dabby encountered
endeavor for the first time
and now this reveal happens you know
like i said exactly
100 chapters later on the dot so clearly
he's been planning this out
very precisely and i can only commend
him for that it's
honestly amazing work the scene then
pans back to the hospital
with rey watching on the tv from the
translations we have so far
debbie goes on to call himself
toyotaroki in this broadcast
and states that he was born the oldest
son of the endeavor family
toyo goes on to reveal that he has
killed more than 30 innocent people
across the course of his life
and now he wants everyone to know what
led him to do these terrible
things clearly toya's plan to destroy
society's faith in heroes
is to let them know that the number one
hero is the one who led him down this
path of villainy
i mean no wonder he's been so happy
recently i
imagine that next chapter debbie will
elaborate on exactly what happened to
him
and maybe my theory about him and hawks
being in the government training program
will be revealed um but yeah for now
this is all we have we don't exactly
know why
he has all these scars and everything
like that but you know what
next chapter i i'm assuming it will come
back to the battlefield
we see the horrified expressions of both
shoto and endeavour
as they react to the news that the
eldest todoroki sun
who they assumed to just died is
standing in front of them
and is on the side of the villains
imagine how they must feel right now
i mean yeah we as an audience suspected
dabi as toyah for a long time
by the way check out my video breaking
down all the clues but
todoroki you know he had no idea that
debbie was toyah neither did endeavor
so this is just probably the most
shocking news they've ever heard in
their lives
toya genuinely starts dancing like the
joker and says that he's been thinking
about
all the ways to make endeavour's life
miserable he tells the number one hero
to his face
that he was wrong to think he could just
move past his previous actions
and that the past cannot be erased the
final panel is a close-up
of both shoto and endeavour and dabi
tells his dad that he can dance with him
in hell which uh concludes this chapter
i gotta say that when my hero academia
is over whenever that will be
this right here will be will go down as
one of its most iconic chapters i mean
yeah it's just amazing like finally we
got it guys we got it
it feels great even though like i said
we all knew he was toyah
but we just needed this we just needed
this reveal and
hopefully in the next few chapters we
elaborate on it a bit more you know
the backstory but i can't tell you how
excited i was when i saw these spoilers
in the morning
and uh for those that don't know every
sunday i do a page by page reaction to
the latest chapters on twitch
so obviously i'll be doing it again this
week so you do not want to miss that
it'll be 5 p.m uk time which i believe
is like 1 p.m
uh eastern time in america um so yeah be
sure to check out my twitch stream
and of course you know for the rest of
this week i'll also be doing a couple
more
debbie toya videos just explaining a few
more things but until the next one
peace out